[Applause]
thank you very much you humble me but
you can gentlemen thank you thank you
thank guy I I think I I think I know why
you're happy today
this Russian spy novel we've all been
reading turns out to be a real
page-turner doesn't it I mean first the
National I mean first the next scenario
I'm going through puberty the National
Security Advisor has to step down
because we found out he was lying about
talking to the Russians
now our Attorney General this week a
thousand year old cracker named Jeff
Sessions he had to recuse himself from
the investigation yeah and you know
Trump said I don't know anybody remember
you struck know anyone who doesn't talk
to the Russian it's like six degrees of
Kevin Putin what what risk
what is this administration always
reading with the right they meet with
the Russians more than the elliptic
doping committee yes from said I don't
know anybody he was asked that a
Prescott did you know anybody doll I
don't know anybody I've heard anybody
okay the National Security Advisor his
campaign manager his son-in-law and now
his attorney general have met with the
Ambassador from Russia Sergey kiss-kiss
lahic gosh the fact that you shouldn't
be meeting with anyone with that name
unless they're a you bird uber driver I
mean I'm trying to think of an innocent
explanation why all these people are
meeting with this [ __ ] he's
their pas stealer
he went to Trump Tower in December I
guess through the backdoor cuz nobody
strong to meet with the son-in-law and
Flynn and the White House said today
well it was just a brief meeting yeah
well it probably didn't have to be more
than a brief meeting you know they said
thank you for stealing the election
[Applause]
and he said don't forget we still have
Pete tape you're welcome
but we fill on seesnake I mean Trump is
pissed off because the the oldest Russia
talk this week poured cold water on what
he thought was his big triumph on
Tuesday did you see his speech he made a
big boy
speech to potty-train Trump went before
Congress to give it address and he stuck
to the teleprompter and everybody said
that he came across is much more
dignified and much more mature actually
what happened was it somebody from Price
Waterhouse gave him the wrong speech
it's not that's it everybody saw the
Oscars oh my god that accountant who
gave Warren Beatty the wrong envelope he
got fired this week yeah and he he
turned in his letter of resignation and
they said this is your water bill and
you know what we know now we found out
why this guy screwed up he was
constantly distracted in his job because
he was always on Twitter thank God we
don't let that kind of idiot do anything
important
[Music]
[Applause]
but I must say for me the most
depressing part of this week was the
media I did a long thing at the end of
our show last week is encouraging the
media thinking they're getting back at
it okay fell on deaf ears uh Trump gets
up there Tuesday night for one hour he
lashes himself to the mast and refrains
from yelling at department stores and
making fun of the handicapped and the
media's like he became president tonight
he read words off a teleprompter in
front of adults the same thing the Olsen
twins did at 7:00
[Applause]
[Music]
really media seriously on the scale of
easily fooled this ranks somewhere
between Mormonism and throwing the bowl
for the dog and percent NPR NPR said
Trump pushed the reset button tonight
okay we have a defective president we're
not going to get better by unplugging
him and then plugging him back in reset
button and if you saw this speech I mean
it was an hour of mostly [ __ ] they
said he lied 51 times low for him
of course he promised to get tough on
crime that's his big thing especially
said after what happened Sunday night in
Hollywood when black people robbed those
white folks of their gold
[Music]
[Applause]
now in cabinet news Rick Perry and Ben
Carson dopey and sleepy have been
confirmed for their confident
appointment they were sworn in by Mike
Pence he said to dr. ben Carson raise
your right eyelid and repeat after me
but don't worry about them as far as the
Russian [ __ ] goes these guys have never
had any contact with intelligence I can
vouch for that
but but okay I mean they're dummies but
you know what he expected this
administration of people I think because
of the speech and the Russian stuff
missed the big story of the week one of
the big stories which is Trump unveiled
what he was going to do about health
care and he said you know what nobody
knew health care could be so complicated
I can't believe Putin paid full price
for this right
nobody knew health care could be self
complicate I love the way to stay is
constantly discovering things we've all
known forever and then pronouncing no
one ever knew it it's like your mechanic
popping up in the hood Jesus Christ
there's a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ]